thanks to brilliant for helping support
this episode
hey crazies we all know light takes time
to get places right it does travel at
300 million meters per second that's 30
centimeters per nanosecond or about 670
million miles per hour
light could travel around the earth
seven and a half times in a single
second
well assuming you could get it to go in
a circle
it takes us days to get to the moon but
light can get there and back and about
two and a half seconds
no one is saying it isn't fast
but those numbers are still finite we
could easily imagine numbers that are
larger one billion meters per second for
example
why can't light go that speed well
because we think about speeds wrong
[Music]
we tend to think of speed as a rate of
change specifically a time rate of
change
if a car is traveling down the road it's
changing location as time passes
we can take the distance it traveled and
divide by the time it took to travel
that distance that measurement could be
in meters per second or feet per second
or kilometers per hour or miles per hour
or something like that a unit of
distance over a unit of time
so what's the problem with that it fails
at significant fractions of the speed of
light
we might think cars are pretty fast
they're a lot faster than walking or
running planes and spacecraft are even
faster
but none of those are moving anywhere
near the speed of light
even tiny subatomic particles while fast
are traveling slower than light
the speed of light appears to be the
fastest speed fast fast
but what if we're in a rocket traveling
at 90 percent the speed of light and we
launch a projectile at 11 the speed of
light
yeah wouldn't it be 101 percent the
speed of light nope it'll be 92 percent
the speed of light what i told you our
intuitions fail at speeds that fast
if you're in a car driving at 30 miles
per hour and you throw a ball at 15
miles per hour our expectations say
someone standing on the ground should
see that ball going at 45 miles per hour
it's a relatively simple calculation you
just add the numbers together right
wrong
well i mean it works in this specific
example but in general it's wrong
the equation actually has a big
denominator it's just that for the
normal human experience that denominator
is effectively one
for the rocket example it's larger which
lowers the result from 101 percent to 92
percent
why is that denominator even there
because we insist on speed being
distance over time for some reason
like we saw earlier we treat speed as a
rate of change if we take a bunch of
snapshots at various moments we can
graph distance against time
the slope or incline of this line would
be the speed
for another car moving slower the line
would be shallower smaller slope smaller
speed
for a third car moving faster the line
would be steeper larger slope larger
speed
but what if instead of using the slope
we use the angle
a car that isn't moving at all is going
to make a horizontal line on this graph
let's measure all of our angles from
there
infinite speed also known as magical
teleportation would be a vertical line
that's 90 degrees from the horizontal
which should be the biggest angle
possible
all other speeds between 0 and infinity
would be measured as an angle between 0
and 90.
faster objects would have a bigger angle
slower objects a shallower angle
can you just make up a measurement like
that sure why not all measurements are
made up
science do whatever works
as long as your definitions are
logically consistent you're fine
this new way of measuring speed is
logically consistent it just isn't what
you're used to
and believe it or not it happens to be
the better choice
remember our previous example we were in
a car traveling at 30 miles per hour and
we threw a ball at 15.
here's the speed of the car and here's
the speed of the ball each represented
as an angle
the speed of the ball relative to
someone standing on the ground is just
the two angles added together the angles
just add which is the rule we originally
wanted speed to follow
unfortunately traditional speed isn't
measured as the angle of these lines
it's measured as the slope of these
lines those slopes only add together
when the angles are small
in other words when the speeds are slow
if we're talking about rockets and
projectiles going at significant
fractions of the speed of light then
slopes do not simply add together that
means traditional speeds don't simply
add together but the angles still do
to avoid confusion for the rest of this
video i'm going to refer to that new
angle speed as rapidity that way i can
stop saying traditional speed and just
say speed
so long story short speeds only add when
they're small rapidity always adds
the problem with rapidity is that it's
not measured in typical speed units it's
measured in angle units like degrees or
better yet radians since that's a
unitless unit
our intuitions are not built on that but
we can convert trigonometry is the math
that relates the sides of triangles to
their angles it's literally the entire
point of trig
the slope of this path forms a right
triangle and trig tells us the slope is
given by sine over cosine which is just
tangent and we have a nifty identity to
help us add those together
since tangent is just the slope and
slope is just the speed we could easily
rewrite this with speeds instead
the angles may add together but the
slopes do not
that doesn't match the equation from
earlier you big doofus
okay okay you may have noticed a minor
discrepancy in the formulas i gave you
today
here's the one i just gave you and
here's the one from earlier in the video
they're close but there's a minus sign
in one denominator and a plus sign in
the other the one with the plus is the
correct one
why did you get the minus then because i
made an assumption i shouldn't have
can we graph distance against time
absolutely
can we use angles to measure speed yes
and we should we just use the wrong kind
of trigonometry euclidean trigonometry
that's the trig that obeys the normal
rules of geometry
you know like the angles in a triangle
always add up to be 180 degrees
but when we graph distance against time
what we have is space time the space may
be euclidian but space time is not it's
hyperbolic which means we need
hyperbolic trig functions
hey i'm just doing my job all right who
made whacker clone
rule number seven only nick touches the
cloning machine
where was i right hyperbolic trick
you know how regular trig is the unit
circle it's kind of popular in the math
crowd
it's just a circle with a radius of one
you can find all the trig functions on
it sine cosine tangent even the
cotangent secant and cosecant are there
the sine and cosine are special though
because they form the triangle for any
point on the circle
put a unit circle
that's like so formal any ago
how about the unit hyperbola instead if
we pick a point on this thing we can
still make a triangle we can even label
the sides sine and cosine if we want but
we'll add an h on the end so we remember
they're hyperbolic because let's not be
totally ridiculous
anyway this fixes our sine problem
if we swap out the tangents in here for
hyperbolic tangents we get a plus sign
in the denominator
isn't that a bit hand wavy yeah maybe a
little like how do we know space time is
hyperbola oh because of the speed of
light
the speed of light is everything
speeds added together for the car
example but not the rocket example
why not the speed of light
more accurately called the speed of
causality it's exactly 299 million 792
458 meters per second
not only is this the maximum speed at
which two points in space can
communicate it's also a universal
constant
it's exactly this number for all
observers everywhere no matter what this
is not a guess it's an observation
hyperbolic geometry has the same
behavior these paths are called
asymptotes they're the lines that all
these hyperbolas approach but never
quite reach
that sounds a lot like the speed of
light
if we set the slope of those lines to be
the speed of light we get a model that
matches reality very well
now traditionally the axes are reversed
in space-time diagrams
but i'm going to break with tradition to
stay consistent throughout this video if
you want to draw them reversed you can
i'm not your dad
what matters is the result and that's
the same either way
not only does this steadily accelerating
rocket never reached that diagonal speed
that slope
any rocket traveling with any
acceleration has the same limit
speeds along those asymptotes are a
universal constant just like the speed
of light
but why is that constant in upper limit
because hyperbolically it's infinite
what what what i know i know it sounds
crazy but hear me out
let's look at the rapidity instead
that's the angle with the horizontal the
faster the rocket goes the bigger the
rapidity gets but only up to a limit
that asymptote the path of light
that rapidity limit might look like 45
degrees but it's not remember this isn't
euclidean
it's the hyperbolic tangent that relates
rapidity to speed the c is the speed of
light which is just there because
traditional units suck for something
traveling at exactly the speed of light
like light this side would be equal to
one that makes the rapidity infinite not
45 degrees
the rapidity of light is infinite there
are no rapidities faster than light
why can't light go at a billion meters
per second because a billion meters per
second doesn't exist
speeds that fast simply don't make sense
in the context of reality which is an
insight we never would have gotten
without going through all this work
if you want to dive a little deeper into
it today's sponsor brilliant can help
watching videos like this is a great way
to get an overview and learn the basics
but to truly understand this like i do
you need experience with it
brilliant is an amazing tool for
learning stem interactively
you can play around with concepts in
real time they even have a course in
special relativity where you can get
experience with hyperbolic space-time
if you feel stuck it's no big deal
brilliant provides in-depth explanations
to break down the material even more
to get started with a free trial go to
brilliant.org science asylum or click
the link in the description below
the first 200 of you will get 20 off
brilliant's annual premium subscription
it'll also let brilliant know you heard
about them from me which helps out the
channel
so do you want to switch to measuring
speed and angle units
you know you do
thanks for liking and sharing this video
a special thanks goes out to my patreon
patrons and youtube members like alexi
bikoff for all their generous support
don't forget to subscribe if you'd like
to keep up with us and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
for everyone complaining about the drake
equation it was never meant to be
scientifically rigorous it was just
meant to start a conversation at a
conference and if my comment section is
any indication that's something the
drake equation is very good at
anyway thanks for watching